a Russian airstrike on a military base
at bravery Northeast of the Ukrainian
Capital Kiev Drive quickly as they'll
strike again the man says as flames
Light Up The Horizon
the Russians are closing in on the
capital these are the latest satellite
images showing a huge Convoy almost 40
miles long moving south towards Kiev the
convoys tip just 15 miles from the
center
adhes to the west of the capital the
devastation from the weekends fight a
bridge in the town of buhar blown up
we're not sure by whom and total
Destruction on the streets
peace talks on Monday saw very little
progress Beyond a call to meet again and
with Russian helicopters pictured here
positioned at the ready in Belarus
Ukraine's president called for the West
to impose a no-fly zone over his country
evil armed with missiles bombs artillery
Must Be Stopped immediately
to destroy economically to show that
humanity is able to defend itself I
believe that the complete closure of the
sky for Russian missiles planes and
helicopters should be considered in
Cardiff close to the Russian border
evidence of the use of banned cluster
bombs shells which explode to release
numerous little bombers which scatter
across a wider area
Russia appears to be ramping up its
Onslaught on Ukraine with the resistance
tougher than it may have bargained for
at a cost no doubt of more destruction
to this Sovereign land and its civilians
the international criminal court says it
plans to open an investigation into
potential war crimes carried out by
Russia in Ukraine leading up to and
including the invasion
neither Russia nor Ukraine has
signatories to the ICC but Ukraine has
accepted the jurisdiction of the Court
which means the chief prosecutor can
move forward
this is President zielinski signed a
document on Monday requesting immediate
accession to the EU an understandable
course of action for him red rag to a
bull for Vladimir Putin
Diana magnney Sky News Moscow